[Music]
today I want to send a personal and
sincere thank you to every health worker
around the world first responders are
working harder than ever to get us
through this crisis
so who's helping the helpers we have to
help the helpers just ahead who helps
the helpers I had myself struggle but
finding a mast I posted a plea and
within less than twelve hours I had 40
pairs of goggles and about 300 masks
I am the costume director for the
Minnesota Opera we have decided that the
best way to keep our people busy is to
make masks we normally manufacture
design products for performance horses
and riders my team has been working 24/7
to get them out the door and get them to
the people on the front lines
prior to coronavirus we were producing
home goods we have made approximately
5000 masks we switched over from
producing alcohol to producing hand
sanitizer other distilleries are doing
the same thing a lot of companies like
this are stepping up to help
we're picking up PPE supplies and
delivering them directly to health care
professionals fighting cope in nineteen
on the front lines thank you now we're
ready to go
hello people of America uses cassandra
is from washington DC wasn't a kitchen
here the teams are working look at all
of the full of food food food we want to
do something that everyone can eat and
enjoy but also has a lot of flair flavor
in London we are supplying eight
hospitals with hot meals twice a day
most of these meals are and job' Indian
cuisine guys can you say hi we decided
to turn our lights back on yesterday and
figuring out how to help in this crisis
we started cooking meals for people
working in hospitals in the end we just
want to help out wherever we can we're
in front of Saint Francis it's Easter
bringing least 200 meals to the workers
here about ten thousand four hundred
meals they deliver today on buses at 36
designated sites throughout the town so
that's quite a big undertaking that they
did there today
right now we are distributing horrible
hand-washing stations for people
experiencing homelessness around the
country I believe soap and water is a
basic human right I am delivering
groceries for the elderly the disabled
veterans pretty much anybody that needs
assistance during this time it started a
couple weeks ago when I turned 16 I
wanted to find a way to serve and
continue my flight training we found
that there are seven critical access
hospitals in Virginia that we could fly
to and provide medical supplies I own
more plane Siberian Huskies and we've
been delivering groceries and medication
to those who are housebound you want
peanut butter turkey definitely a lot of
work but so worth it yeah she's waving
one day I may need help and this is a
time right now where people need help
from everybody already we've seen people
band together and produce so much it
seems like this is the only way that
we'll be able to get through this thing
find ways to collaborate within your own
community get involved don't feel like
you can't help you can that's the place
where change occurs stay safe let's get
through this together and on the other
side we will be stronger and we'll all
appreciate and
even in the toughest times there are
people help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]